[Music]
hello there you are watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with
political editor at wales online ruth
masalski
and whitehall editor at the financial
times
sebastian payne so let's see what's
on some of those front pages for you now
the guardian
leads on the news that ministers have
apologized to
rape victims saying they've been failed
by the criminal justice system
on the front of the manchester evening
news the damning report on the security
failings that proved
fatal in the manchester arena bombing
that story is also the lead for the
express which says
there were nine missed chances to save
22 lives
one of the scientists behind the oxford
vaccine has called for coronavirus
testing in schools to be scrapped
saying it's disruptive that's on the
front of the telegraph
the mail reports that lockdown
restrictions could end two weeks early
if it becomes clearer that the jabs are
working the metro says that pub
landlords could face fines of a thousand
pounds
for breaking covered rules if football
fans chant or boo
during the england scotland game
and the ft reports that the government
is to put channel four on a path towards
privatization
from as early as next year
well joining me tonight ruth sulsky and
sebastian payne to
take us through the papers good evening
to you both
and before we delve into the papers ruth
i wonder if you can uh respond to the
breaking news that we've had from mark
draper saying that
they've put a pause on that lifting
restrictions in
wales yeah in lots of ways
that is obviously expected the delta
variant is growing here
and cases are foreign and far out the
five cases sorry
a new hero or the delta variant and this
wasn't an official review week for wales
this is um on the back of boris
johnson's announcement about june 21st
being another week ahead of barry view
and that will still happen but
uh mark draper has made it very clear
there's a four week pause now
things are expecting like the rule of
six uh for indoor
um homes he's been paused um
the number of uh extended households
changing that's been paused as well and
um ice rinks which was one of the things
that the welsh government were looking
at
change in this review also posed um
delta variant is causing a lot of
concern wherever you are in the uk
and it's no different here in wales
indeed uh sebastian let's delve into the
the daily mail the front page uh there
could we be
free on july the 5th an earlier
date uh being suggested tell us why
so this is a very interesting
examination of the data that we're
seeing from the coronavirus vaccines and
what the daily mail is suggesting that
in fact
the effectiveness of both the pfizer and
astrogen astrazeneca jab
mean that we could actually exit those
restrictions on july the 5th
now we know that boris johnson's always
had this two-week gap in there and
some in whitehall think it's because the
prime minister always likes to have some
good news and wanted to make things look
more optimistic
but the daily mail splash tomorrow seems
to suggest that actually we could be out
of things
earlier i'm a little bit skeptical of
this because when you look at the
modeling done by
sage and the government's scientific
advisors it's really quite clear they
feel that time is needed to get as many
second jobs
as possible because thanks to the delta
variant of kona virus which originated
in india
it's quite clear that double jabs now
needed across the whole population
as quickly as possible to stop hospitals
being overwhelmed
more unnecessary deaths and the
overwhelming of the health service so
i think at the moment it's interesting
the daily mail is detecting that
actually things are going a bit better
than expected
but fundamentally i don't think the
government's going to challenge it and
there's what lisa was saying about
what's going on in wales
what we've seen in scotland too i think
all the the nations of the uk are
following this trajectory of having a
month of just
putting you know sort of it's taking the
foot off the accelerator was the words
boris johnson used
and i feel like that is going to remain
the case but the thing we should be a
little bit thankful for it's early days
though
is it appears the rate of infections is
beginning to slow and if that continues
over the next few days and it shows the
vaccines are working
and that we are heading out of this
crisis but but ruth why
dangle this earlier date i mean it could
give people
false hope i mean it's another um date
that will be in people's mind uppermost
in their mind that might
have to be dashed again
yeah it's interesting it was uh the
premises spokesman tell journalists on
monday that
while they were going to look at it on
july 5th he thought it was very unlikely
that um we would there would be any
changes for england
and specifically wales and scotland
obviously doing their own thing
um the the june 21st date was very much
in england's mind mark draper has been
clear
for months now that that wasn't going to
be the case here in wales we just
haven't had that date they have
routinely said it's data not dates and
it's interesting that boris johnson is
um
that was hammering that point home a
little more and frequently uh once it
looked like
the june 21st day it wasn't going to be
met july 5th is
is still you know it's still very um
it's not far away we still don't know
although all the signs are good about
delta varying but we still don't know
you know and i think any dangling of
dates just gets people's hopes up and it
just makes you think
well i can have my wedding my
christening my my birthday party and
actually still may not happen
and so i think the caution that wales
has shown on dates
i think mr johnson maybe needs to um
echo from westminster yeah i mean it
does seem almost cruel if
the dates don't materialize let's move
on to the yorkshire
post sebastian and this the the new line
that
over 18s can book their first kobe jab
from tomorrow yes and this shows the
progress the vaccination program is
making across the country here that
obviously the government wants to get a
single job in everyone by july the 19th
when that next stage of easing is meant
to go ahead but of course the real
question after this is what's going to
happen to teenagers
that we've seen that some of the jabs
have been approved for and 12 to 18 year
olds the pfizer jab in particular
but the jcvi which is the independent
committee that oversees vaccination
they've not given the go-ahead you have
a teenager to get vaccinated but i
imagine that's exactly what's going to
happen
in august because we could find
ourselves in a situation when
that final easing does take place on
july the 19th and i think really
when you look at what boris johnson said
what michael gove said
everybody wants that to happen they
don't want this thing to drag on any
longer and
the fact is we are going to have a third
wave of coronavirus and the whole and
there's there's no way of getting around
that but the hope is
that the vac stations provide a wall of
immunity
that means the deaths and the infections
and the serious illnesses are far lower
than they were in the first two waves
but i think
teenagers are quite crucial for when
schools go back in september
and we've seen in america too the pfizer
jab has been authorized for teenagers so
18 year olds they will get jabba then
the question really is what comes next
and the other thing we should note as
well is
if you look at those who are getting
seriously ill from colonel virus at the
moment
it's younger people it's hospitals are
full of those younger people
so that's why the government's clearly
moving forward because that's all part
of the plan to double jab
and then single jab everybody as quickly
as possible yes and i suppose
with lots of um over 18s will be rushing
to get
the first jab um so perhaps they can get
the second in time to go on holiday
because what they're complaining of now
is they're going to be discriminated
against
because they might not be able to to go
on holiday to
ambulance countries without quarantining
on the way back i think kobe's had an
effect on everyone hasn't it doesn't
matter who you are or what your
circumstances are because it's impacted
you
you can see why young people might think
hang on i'd put my university on hold or
i didn't get my degree ceremony or i
didn't get to you know leave school in
the way that other people did
and they rightly feel that a lot of
their formative years have been taken
away from them and i fully sympathize
with them as with lots of other people
and
different ages um here in wales 18 year
olds are already being dropped um our
current rate is 67.5
and that's can only be good news you
know we we need these young people to be
jabbed
so that like sebastian says the
hospitals aren't full of younger people
it's why both governments um have said
this week that they're delaying things
because they want to get those
vaccination numbers up and mark wait
during the statement tonight when he's
putting these measures on ports has said
that there's going to be half a million
um extra you know jabs put out within
that period
so to really build up as much immunity
as possible and with cases going up here
delta variant cases going up here by 184
since monday
you can completely see why every one of
those jobs is absolutely vital
and young people are no different they
want their jobs they want their freedoms
back and we can't blame them for that i
don't think
indeed indeed ruth and sebastian for the
minute thank you
coming up the missed chances what went
wrong
the day of the manchester bombing at the
cost of the lives of 22
innocent people
welcome back you are watching the press
preview
still with me the political editor from
wales online ruth nasalski
and whitehall editor at the financial
times sebastian payne welcome back to
both of you
um let's have a look at the telegraph
um ruth and the politics of the dup
their leader has now quit after only
three weeks in the job
yeah it's been another busy day in north
island i think each time i've seen the
news today that
the story has changed um he's only
officially been leader for 21 days
and there was a big internal party
backlash about a a deal done
about the irish language um brandon
lewis announced that this morning
which committed that the british
government was going to intervene if
the storm and assembly failed to do so
by then september um
but some within mr putin's parties ought
the deal get to move to chine
um and throughout the night there was a
there was a meeting
uh various people going in coming out
being box popped by my colleagues in
northern ireland
and it's not being announced that he's
resigned um it not only throws obviously
that deal on the irish language into um
into question but it opens up the
possibilities of a snap election in
northern ireland and as your
correspondence described earlier it puts
the dep themselves into free fall
and it's a huge huge story that's got so
many different chapters and so many
different questions
um and the bbc of um bbc's james
mccormack has said tonight that
even by recent standards it's been a
remarkable 24 hours
and i don't think anyone can argue with
her there uh sebastian and what are your
thoughts as to who will
uh replace mr putz
well it's been one of the most traumatic
um 24 hours in northern irish politics
which even by the standards
of the rest of the uk has manages to be
the most
complex and the most vicious um mr putz
has been needed for 20 days the dup and
he was very instrumental
in ousting arlene foster who was the
previous dup leader and was also
first minister of northern ireland and
fundamentally there's been a dispute
about this irish language act which shin
fein see is absolutely crucial
um to em to going back into government
with the dup
that proved too much for mr putin's
colleagues and so
they went straight from voting against
his choice to first minister to voting
against
him and he's now out we'll have yet
another dup leadership election
and the person who's mochas like to
place him is sir jeffrey donaldson he
was his contenders challenger
for the leadership and puts beat him by
just one vote you imagine that's where
the action is going to be now
but fundamentally this is a very
dangerous place for
and politics in northern ireland to be
because this all came about because the
tensions resulting from brexit
and the fact this the northern ireland
protocol has created deep
deep unhappiness within the eunice
community there's no clear resolution to
this
and yes maybe jeffrey donaldson becomes
the next dup leader
but how is he going to do a deal with
shin fein with or without the irish
language act if he can't do that deal
then you could see the whole
administration collapse pour into
another set of elections
and we'll be back to the same old
stalemate we've seen for quite some time
and it's just at the dups under intense
political pressure
on its right flank it's got the
traditional oster voice party which is
pushing it
into a more hard-line direction and then
on the left you've got this traditional
uup which are the osce unionist party
and the fact is the dup is really
trapped between these two forces and
arlene foster
was a general moderate in these senses
and trying to balance both of those
yes she's uh she's tweeted she's tweeted
earlier today saying that she was um
having a a great time a bit of a smirk
on her face i think you could imagine
let's have a look at the
metro and the inquiry into the
manchester arena bombing and
their headline then saying he should
have been spotted
that a baby should have been spotted
many failings being pointed out ruth
yeah i mean you can't help but read this
report and just feel feel sorry for
everyone involved you know
the the families have been through so
much already and now to hear that there
were these chances formally
and must just be heartbreaking i think
it's credit to them in the interviews
i've seen with them
since this report came out that they're
working for change they want to see
things
and made better they want to see this
not happen again and no one else go
through it
and that means sitting through these
painful reports which there's going to
be three
and learning those lessons and and
hearing what what did
go wrong i mean there's things of police
um officers going five miles
for a kebab on the night there's
pictures of the four bridges transport
police um
officers who are on duty in the um
further away in the train station rather
than in the foyer where they should have
been
there's the the evidence of the member
of the public who who saw the bomber
and and tipped off the security guard
only for his walkie-talkie not to work
you know there's
there's there's really damning um and
really sad
um parts of this report that are coming
out
um hindsight is a brilliant thing um but
we've all had to live unfortunately with
um life with uh terror events
uh in recent years uh thankfully
touchwood they've
they've eased obviously given um current
circumstances but we are going to get
back to that world and people need to
know that they can
um go about their lives and go to things
like gigs and
large venues and feel safe and there's
there's
it just sounds like there's gonna be an
awful lot more details coming out that
these families say he's going to be
absolutely horrific and heartbreaking he
can only hope they keep the dignity that
they've been showing today
yeah as you say ruth painful for the
victims
and their families